so okay please don't put a dick in my
face okay I got a dick it's a dildo
still oh it's a ball vaginas are insane
no more bold vaginas and penises hey
guys my name is Kate Siegel and this is
Kim Friedman known on Instagram as the
crazy Jewish mom our Instagram followers
are constantly asking for my mom's sex
advice and relationship questions so
we're gonna answer a few of those right
now what do you think is the most
important advice you can give to a
teenager who's thinking about having sex
one men think with their penis second
piece of advice is get tested and get
tested together you have some wine you
get tested then you know they're
teenagers so no no wonders is it true
that a man won't buy the cow if he gets
the milk for free you go out for a while
you have good sex it's really hot it's
really fabulous you know each other make
a decision don't waste time go because
what both ways if you're getting the
milk for free if he's getting the milk
for free
all the milk is free Wow gonna make me
hot tips for first time pegging tops so
pegging is when you take you strap on a
dildo take my dildo and you put it on
over using my as a model you said that's
fun and you didn't have like a cute
little negligee onto a little bra or
something to make it sexy the strapless
trap one's kinky we got just oh oh it's
vibrating what is your worst sex
experience you've ever had I had this
fantasy that I wanted to have sex in
Central Park we kind of like hid in the
bushes we realized that we were lying in
dog poop oh wow after marriage
Oh God you know what any relationships
there's a lot of give-and-take so I
would say yes to a generous Act
you ever faked it yeah ah we're gonna do
a speed round now punch them from
Instagram it's pitiful spit spit spit
popper bottom doesn't move that bottom
anal annoying no anal sex toys are no
sex toys sex toy he has sex on the first
date yes or no no never kissing on the
first date you yes or no yes how long
should you be in a relationship before
you decide to get married six months
what's your favorite sex toy pegging is
what my mother has so kindly volunteered
to explain to me how all of these lovely
sex toys provided by BuzzFeed work yeah
although you're gonna make sure it's
this side up as none you go down go down
go down
blow up this is fabulous this is you you
have to get you turn it on it's a
vibrant and you know what else you can
use this for I have a bad back sometimes
so I'm gonna take this no no no no anal
beads do you know where your anus is yes
it already knows you do you put them in
and then you go like that you don't even
know it's I know what it's cause I told
you right but now it took it's a it's a
conference oh he's starting to run are
they your Kegel balls you want to keep
the vagina tight and this is the way you
keep the vagina tight it's fabulous
fabulous moisturize you're not I hope
we've really educated you and you know
what okay maybe anything else move your
face do it as long as you got tested
first and you're using perfect
absolutely while you're doing just slap
it down on the desk